springing Glenn Ordway great radio host
WEEI in Boston has his regular weekly
visit with Bill Belichick and he joins
us now Glenn thanks for joining us what
do you make of this well here's what I
make of it Dan one Bill Belichick was
adamant yesterday and you as you know
that's not necessarily his style
sometimes you'll downplay stuff
low-key it because he doesn't want to
talk about it he wanted to talk about it
there was no question the other thing I
can tell you from sources within the
Patriots organization is they know they
screwed up internally but it was not the
football operations department so as you
know these football teams now they
become marketing Giants and they've got
their own content departments production
departments and so it was something
outside of the football operation but
I've talked to somebody who has actually
knowledge of what is on that SD card and
a way it was described to me it is
longer than eight minutes on the
sideline I don't know the exact time
limit on it but what they did is they
sat down with the scout before the game
they asked him exactly what he does
they're doing a whole series of things
they did one on their trainer Jim Whelan
earlier in the year and they're doing it
for their production company so they sit
down with the Scout they say what are
you looking for well I'm looking for
personnel changes and when they're going
to change purse to know so they get a
bunch of information from him as to what
his job is
and then they set a fixed camera on a
tripod set it up and tried to go and get
b-roll for each one of those things that
he claimed he watches for so I'm sure
the league is going to see that tape and
they're gonna see a lot of the sidelines
because that's what a scout does the
question is was it done for football
purposes or was it done for production
TV production so the team's you know
digital wing of the organization the NFL
is going to have to determine that but
can you plead ignorance can that be your
defense here and then the Commissioner
might show some leniency I don't think
it's ignorant about a fact I'm hearing
just the opposite from people within the
page
three it's organization now the football
operation is denying everything as
Belichick did yesterday on my show there
did I get on two percent a knew nothing
about it I'm hearing from other people
that the yes they went out of their way
to set up their crew in Cincinnati in
this or this game in Cleveland they
worked with Cleveland to do it they're
pleading that they should have had much
closer raps on it they shouldn't have
allowed it to just happen they should
have gone through what is the protocol
are we going to get ourselves into
trouble and let's face it then there's a
reputation with the organization's it
need to be are you sure are you sure but
you you know Bill Belichick pretty well
the fact that he showed this I don't
know if that's anger
like how upset he was how much to read
into that knowing what his personality
is a lot I I was thoroughly convinced
and it was the first question I was
going to ask him when he walked into the
studio I can tell a lot of times from
him on knowing him for you know over 20
years dealing with him you know if he
wants to talk about something or not I
was thoroughly convinced that bill knows
nothing about it now I also was
convinced that bill knows this is not a
good thing for the organization he knows
the way it's going to be perceived
nationally the way it's going to be
played up I mean first of all if you if
you're going to self Scout and you're
going to cheat would you do it against
the Cincinnati Bengals why wouldn't you
do it against Kansas City here last week
or Baltimore a few weeks ago their
second of all if you're going to do it
why would you do it with somebody that's
wearing Patriot paraphernalia and one of
the cameramen apparently was wearing
Boston Bruins paraphernalia you sneak
somebody in the stands you get a fixed
camera you got 4k stuff in your iPhone's
down and you can grab all the
information you need it makes no sense
maybe they just got caught this time
around Glenn anything I just think
that this is one of those it's going to
look really bad so if you say that the
Patriots have been cheaters in the past
this just gives you more ammunition and
obviously to me it doesn't seem like
they did anything wrong is it possible I
will say this if the NFL sits down
watches that video on the SD card and
sees three hours of a fixed camera on
the sideline then they're probably going
to throw a heavy fine or draft picks or
something with into England Patriots if
the NFL can't tell the difference
between footage that is used to apply to
the to the game versus the b-roll that
is used for a television production then
something's wrong I gotta believe
they're going to be able to figure it
out
could this be a good thing for the
Patriots no have you watched this now
I'm hearing that all this is going to
rally the Patriots usually when they're
cheating they're winning Super Bowl
Talent if you can find like a couple of
receivers maybe Antonio Brown brahim
back then maybe you could fix this thing
I mean offensively they are really
challenged special teams and defense is
great it reminds me of the fritzy 2015
Denver Broncos you know where they had
the great defense their offense suck
Peyton Manning was really at the end
actually Tom Brady right now is I put
think playing a lot better than Payton
played that year and yet Denver wanted
what do you make of what Tom Curren
reported about Brady that you'd kind of
land the breadcrumbs down that you could
see a mutual parting here Belichick
makes that decision to say you know what
we're moving on to another quarterback
here or next season yeah I I think
anything is possible with Bill Belichick
because he is not going anywhere I would
not be surprised to see Bill coach for
another five years he's got his sons in
the operation right now I think it's
like the Shanahan family and others
before them but you know they're going
to continue the coaching legacy so I
don't think he's going anywhere as you
know tom is excellent Tom Curren is
excellent at this stuff he's got real
tight tie-ins
the Brady family but I think it all
comes down to the Patriots I think if
the Patriots want Tom Brady back Tom
Brady is back if the Patriots don't I
don't think Tom Brady is done playing
football
I really don't and I think he wants to
play for at least 45 I think he still
believes he can do it he's having fun
even with all these young people around
him he seems to be energized Pryor I
think he'll play for somebody else if
the Patriots won't have them but I find
it hard to believe that the Patriots are
going to move on without Tom Brady
because I don't see a quarterback
anywhere the Stidham kid can't do it
they traded Garoppolo away where's their
quarterback Eli Manning hey how did you
get Belichick to agree to do a weekly
radio show you know I I've been asked
before if I've ever met Bill Belichick
and I always tell them there's only I
was only around him one time we've never
had him on but I think it was the night
of the bud fumble and he walked out onto
the field and I was with Rodney Harrison
and Tony Dungy and so he shakes their
hands and I'm the next guy in line but I
don't put my hand out too far so it's
not too embarrassing if he doesn't shake
my hand and he just blows right by me
and I pulled my hand back hoping that
nobody saw any of that so really yeah
but even when I'm handing him a Super
Bowl trophy it's not like you know
there's any small talk there but you
know I tell coach I said although that's
I guess that's what I'm getting well
yeah just interview next week just say
hey coach Dan Patrick's and lo I will
bring it up who's that yeah Dan Patrick
he's been around a long time
it's great to talk to you Glenn thank
you to kill you buddy
that's a Glenn Ordway he's one of the
King radio kings there in Boston WEEI
2:00 to 6:00 in the afternoon for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]